the Emperor's New Clothes once upon a
time there was an emperor he had a big
round belly bushy eyebrows and a very
long mustache but he was very vain all
he thought about was himself
I am so wonderful he would say look at
my wonderful eyebrows look at my
excellent moustache I look marvelous
the Emperor loved to wear fancy clothes
he had four hundred fancy shirts 300
pairs of fancy pants and 1000 pairs of
fancy socks the Emperor also loved to
say fancy words like empirical
cantankerous discombobulated he didn't
know what the fancy words meant but he
liked to say them anyway he liked to
sound intelligent I am so intelligent he
said I am a genius one day a man arrived
at the palace he said that he was a
tailor he said he could make the
fanciest clothes in the land but really
this man was a dishonest man he earned
his money by fooling rich people the
tailor brought the Emperor ten suitcases
your most majestic and intelligent
majesty he said everybody knows that you
are the most intelligent man in the
world and I have created some amazing
new clothes
these clothes are only for intelligent
people in fact stupid people cannot even
see these clothes
the Emperor clapped his hands amazing
with these clothes I can know who is
smart and who is stupid I will never be
bothered by idiots again
let me try these clouds the tailor
undressed the Emperor until he stood
only in his underpants he unpacked his
tape measure he measured the Emperor's
arms legs shoulders and all around his
big round belly the tailor reached
inside one of the suitcases now no this
one is too big no this one is too small
this one is perfect he pretended to lift
a shirt out of the suitcase what do you
think said the tailor the Emperor gasped
he could not see anything he isn't it
wonderful said the tailor and remember
only intelligent people will be able to
see it the tailor reached into his
suitcase again look at these pants
they're beautiful and they are
completely invisible to idiots and look
at this jacket see the colors a complete
nincompoop will see absolutely nothing
oh yes yes very nice stammered the
Emperor but he was confused why couldn't
he see the clothes surely it's not
possible that I am an idiot he thought a
complete would not know fancy
words like vestibule crepuscular liberty
gym it but the emperor said nothing the
tailor pretended to dress the emperor in
the invisible shirt pants jacket and
shoes the emperor stood in front of the
mirror he wanted to see the clothes but
all he saw was his big round belly and
his underpants I'm not sure that it's
really my style said the Emperor but let
me get a second opinion
the Emperor called three of his most
intelligent friends into the room
what do you think of these new clothes
only intelligent people can see these
clothes stupid people see nothing at all
of course
his friends didn't see anything either
but they did not want to look stupid oh
he's a great said the first friend yes
the pants are the perfect color said the
second friend cool shoes said the third
friend the Emperor was excited I will
wear these new clothes in the parade
tomorrow the Emperor gave the tailor a
lot of money the tailor left a palace
with ten suitcases full of gold when he
was safely in his carriage he laughed
long and hard what a doofus
that night the Emperor did not sleep he
stayed up late reading the biggest
heaviest books in his library I just
need a few more fancy words then I'll be
able to see my clothes he thought in the
morning two servants came to the
Emperor's room to dress him for the
parade of course they couldn't see any
clothes either but they said nothing
they did not want to look stupid they
pretended to dress the Emperor in
invisible pants invisible shirt
invisible jacket and an invisible hat
the Emperor looked at himself in the
mirror he stared and he squinted he
turned his head left and right and wait
there it was out of the corner of his
eye he thought he saw a slight
shimmering fabric a checkered pattern a
tiny bit of color he could see the
clothes in reality there were no clothes
but we often see what we want to see the
Emperor was happy that he could finally
see the clothes
let's join the parade he shouted
everybody from the town was at the
parade all the intelligent people were
there all the scientists all the writers
all the teachers and all the children
the Emperor's stood in his open carriage
and waved to the crowd but as the
Emperor's carriage drove down the street
the crowd fell silent the music stopped
everybody stared at the Emperor these
clothes must be amazing filt the Emperor
but then from the back of the crowd a
small child yelled buddy I could see his
underpants
everybody gasped then there were a few
giggles and then everyone on the street
laughed and laughed and laughed even
harder they clapped and shouted the
Emperor heard the crowd laugh he knew he
had been fooled he wasn't wearing
special clothes he was wearing nothing
only his underpants he jumped out of the
carriage and ran all the way back to the
palace behind him he heard he ran to his
bedroom and slammed the door later when
his friends found him he was lying on
his bed he was wearing all his real
clothes all his fancy shirts all his
fancy pants and all 1000 pairs of fancy
socks
[Music]